après dix ans d'absence laurent gbagbo
est rentré en côte d'ivoire
définitivement acquittés par la cour
pénale internationale
le retour de l'ancien président au nom
de la réconciliation nationale n'a pas
forcément eu antic a en tout cas pour
l'instant l'effet escompté
nicolas petit ce sont ses premiers pas
en côte d'ivoire depuis dix ans laurent
gbagbo vient d'atterrir à l'aéroport
d'abidjan pour accueillir l'ancien
président des dirigeants de son parti le
front populaire ivoirien des proches et
plusieurs dizaines de notament le front
populaire ivoirien souhaité que le
retour au pays de laurent gbagbo soient
populaires mais il n'en est rien déjà
privé d'adieu à ses soutiens lors de son
décollage à bruxelles l'homme fort du
pays de 2000 à 2010 est encore tenu à
l'écart de ses partisans sur le sol
ivoirien
la police fait usage de gaz lacrymogènes
pour disperser la foule avant même son
arrivée
une situation dénoncée par le parti de
l'ancien président nous sommes étonnés
au moment où les gens s'apprêtent à lui
le président laurent gbagbo qu'ils
soient gaz est là qu avec des bombes
lacrymogènes
tout alla au carrefour akwaba au grand
carrefour de koumassi
il ya eu des jeunes personnes qui sont
venues qui ont été gazés on apprend que
le cas répond d'aquabike avant
d'interpeller déjà on ne comprend pas
cours pourtant placé sous le signe de la
réconciliation nationale par alassane
ouattara qui l'a d'ailleurs pas fait le
déplacement
ce retour n'a pas vraiment des allures
de fête
malgré ses dix années passées loin de la
côte d'ivoire dont une bonne partie en
prison
laurent gbagbo a conservé une forte ora
au prix d'une partie de la population
ivoirienne en particulier les jeunes
certains d'entre eux se font déjà une
idée bien précise de la suite des
événements dans la politique il ne peut
pas donner ça maintenant
le temps n'est pas encore arrivé pour
que cela m'a donné il va les voir
continuer en phase de poules eu d'éclat
de voix oppressée mandat avec laurent
gbagbo dans ses rangs l'opposition est
également porté par le parti
démocratique de côte d'ivoire de
l'ancien président henri konan-bédié
pourrait prendre de l'épaisseur
définitivement acquitté de crimes contre
l'humanité est de retour dans son pays
l'horizon politique semble désormais
dégagée pour laurent gbagbo
un horizon aux allures de promesses
pour louis keumayou président du club de
l'information africaine laurent gbagbo a
été accueillie comme un leader politique
mais pas comme un chef d'état
aujourd'hui il revient avec des honneurs
qui lui sont refusés
même s'il rentre en tant qu' en tant
qu'ancien chef d'état et qu'il est
accueillie comme telle
yam néanmoins il ya néanmoins cette
volonté de le maintenir dans la position
de leader politique d'un camp plutôt que
deux hommes d'état qui pourrait fédérer
l'ensemble des ivoiriens et prendre sa
part active dans le processus de
réconciliation du pays
laurent gbagbo a déjà un héritage
politique est celui de d'avoir eu le
courage de lutter pour le multipartisme
à un moment où le premier président de
la côte d'ivoire houphouët boigny pour
ne pas le citer était encore dans sa
toute puissance
et comme personne ne contestait son
autorité il n'a jamais oublié qu'il
était un homme politique il est féru
d'histoire et je ne sais pas s'ils
maintiennent la scène volonté d'agir en
tant qu'acteur partie prenante de la vie
politique ou de devenir le sèche qui
pourrait aujourd'hui à la manière d'un
mc mandela fédérer d'abord sa famille
politique
ensuite les ivoiriens entre eux pour
qu'ils fassent nation ça c'est la chose
qui est la plus difficile à prévoir mais
une chose est certaine c'est que gbagbo
en revenant en côte d'ivoire ne tire pas
un trait sur son histoire politique